el periodista guatemalteco José Rubén
Zamora tiene previsto para hoy su juicio
en el tribunal octavo de Sentencia de
ciudad de Guatemala la fiscalía especial
contra la impunidad lo acusa de tres
cargos lavado de dinero chantaje y
tráfico de influencias lleva nueve meses
en prisión y en una anterior audiencia
en la que se le imputó un nuevo cargo el
de Conspiración para la obstrucción de
la justicia Zamora denunció que un
guarda de la cárcel donde se encuentra
detenido la Mariscal Zavala golpeó
durante toda la noche los barrotes de su
celda para que llegara insomne a la cita
judicial en esta oportunidad Zamora
llega sin abogados que lo defiendan de
manera que será el periodista quien
enfrente su propia defensa material una
de las pruebas en su contra más
significativas es la de 300.000
quetzales en efectivo el equivalente a
40 mil dólares que Zamora le habría
entregado a un antiguo gerente de banco
para que este emitiera un cheque a favor
de el periódico el medio de comunicación
que Zamora fundó y del cual es
presidente solo por este cargo de lavado
de dinero Zamora podría enfrentar hasta
20 años de prisión y desde organismos
internacionales como la sociedad
Interamericana de prensa se pide su
Liberación así como se han denunciado
irregularidades de su proceso teniendo
en cuenta que fue un caso construido en
apenas 72 horas previas a su detención y
posteriores a la publicación de un
artículo en el periódico que criticaba
actos de corrupción en los que se
involucra el presidente guatemalteco
Alejandro yamate